pruebas obligatorias de covi 19 para
todos los Hong konges la líder del
territorio carrilam tomó la decisión
ante el desmesurado aumento de contagios
ya está excediendo nuestra capacidad
para hacerle frente es por eso que
necesitamos del apoyo de las autoridades
centrales para que podamos combatir la
pandemia estrategia de contención
la medida causa reacciones encontradas
No creo que el gobierno
debería considerar aumentar la mano de
obra y las instalaciones de los
hospitales
las pruebas universales obligatorias son
algo bueno pero todos depende de si el
gobierno realmente pueda aislar
inmediatamente a las personas infectadas
tras las pruebas
de la Universidad de Hong Kong
advirtieron que los nuevos contagios
podrían alcanzar la cifra de 180,000 al
día el próximo mes los contagios diarios
se han multiplicado por 70 lo que ha
desbordado las capacidades de análisis
hospitalización y cuarentena Hong Kong
ha tenido fuertes restricciones como la
prohibición de llegada de vuelos de
Estados Unidos y Reino Unido medida que
se mantendrá hasta el 20 de abril
también prohibió las reuniones de más de
dos personas y decidió el cierre de la
mayoría de los locales incluidas las
escuelas los gimnasios y los salones de
belleza hasta el momento la ciudad ha
registrado más de 60,000 contagios